Kennt ihr Reifebeschleuniger? Nicht? Esst ihr aber in billiger Salami!
Traditionelle Metzger lassen Salami fünf Wochen reifen.
Viel zu lang - findet Sebastian Lege!
Er verrät euch heute den Reifetrick.
SEBASTIAN: "48 Stunden und dann ist die Salami fix und fertig."
Egal ob Discounter-Salami oder Markenprodukt - viele Hersteller tricksen.
Denn Zeit ist Geld. Lange Reifezeit machen ein Produkt teuer.
Also verkürzen sie die mit Zusatzstoffen.
Unter den Namen "Reifekulturen" oder "Starterkulturen" finden wir den Zusatz bei vielen Salamiprodukten.
Daher kostet Salami im Supermarkt nur fünf Euro pro Kilo,
während man beim Metzger locker mal 20 Euro pro Kilo zahlt.
Sebastian Lege lüftet den Trick dahinter.
Zusammen mit Metzgermeister Peter Inhofen geht es jetzt um die Wurst.
Traditionelle Herstellung tritt an gegen Industrietrick.
SEBASTIAN: "Peter, wie lange braucht deine Salami bis sie bei mir auf dem Brötchen landet?"
PETER: "Circa vier Wochen."
"Wir müssen erstmal das Fleisch zerkleinern
und nach dem Zerkleinern würzen und so weiter, dann lagern wir das."
[Vorspul-Effekt]
Halt, stopp! Zu viel Arbeit!
Sebastian kann's schneller!
Und zwar mit Glucon Delta Lacton oder kurz GDL.
SEBASTIAN: "Mit Zusatz meines Reifebeschleunigers brauchen wir nur
48 Stunden und dann ist die Salami fix und fertig."
Expressreifung also. Aus fünf Wochen werden 48 Stunden.
Für unsere Gesundheit gilt das als unbedenklich.
Klar, dass die Industrie das Zeug in großen Mengen einsetzt.
Mehr Wurst in weniger Zeit: ein Knaller.
Und es wird noch besser: Wenn die Wurst schneller reift, geht weniger Wasser und damit Gewicht verloren.
Das spart 15 bis 20 Prozent Fleisch.
PETER: "Man sieht jetzt schon eine kleine Farbveränderung."
"Meine braucht - um deine Farbintensität zu bekommen - mindestens vier bis fünf Stunden."
"Ist schon ein Unterschied. Das finde ich beeindruckend, wie schnell das geht."
Für Sebastians Express-Salami geht es jetzt 48 Stunden in die Reifekammer
Der traditionellen Salami steht jetzt noch wochenlanges Trocknen bevor, wohingegen die Express-Salami....
[FANFARE]
SEBASTIAN: "Das sieht ja aus wie eine waschechte Salami."
Die 98 Prozent Zeitersparnis sieht man der Wurst nicht an.
Kein Unterschied zur fünf Wochen gereiften Wurst.
Aber wie schmeckt's?
PETER: "Die ist langweiliger."
SEBASTIAN. "Die ist so... flach, langweilig, sauer, salzig vorne."
"Dein Produkt schmeckt wesentlich klarer. Nussig."
PETER: "Danke! Waren auch fünf Wochen Liebe!"
Klar, dass bei dem Tempo der Geschmack leidet.
Salami mit Reifebeschleuniger schmeckt leicht säuerlich.
Für uns der Hinweis, dass da mit Chemie nachgeholfen wurde.
Ihr denkt das ist schon alles? Nee!
Das Pulver kann noch viel mehr!
Es hilft auch Käse beim Reifen und wird in vielen Milchprodukten eingesetzt,
die erst nach dem Abfüllen fest werden sollen.
Es lässt Teigwaren schön gleichmäßig aufgehen
und sogar in Obst- und Gemüsekonserven finden wir es.
Dort erhält es die Farbe.
Übrigens: Glucon Delta Lacton wird nicht nur unter dem Namen Reifekulturen angegeben.
Wird es als Säuerungsmittel eingesetzt, versteckt es sich auch unter "E575".
Lust auf noch mehr turboschnelle Tricks, Checks und Duelle aus der Welt der Lebensmittel?
Dann ab auf unseren Kanal ZDFbesseresser!